Five years ago,
I stood on the TED stage
and warned about the dangers
of superintelligence.
I was wrong.
It went even worse than I thought.
(Laughter)
I never thought governments
would let AI companies get this far
without any meaningful regulation.
And the progress of AI
went even faster than I predicted.
Look, I showed this abstract
landscape of tasks
where the elevation represented
how hard it was for AI
to do each task at human level.
And the sea level represented
what AI could be back then.
And boy or boy, has the sea
been rising fast ever since.
But a lot of these tasks have already
gone blub blub blub blub blub blub.
And the water is on track
to submerge all land,
matching human intelligence
at all cognitive tasks.
This is a definition of artificial
general intelligence, AGI,
which is the stated goal
of companies like OpenAI,
Google DeepMind and Anthropic.
And these companies are also trying
to build superintelligence,
leaving human intelligence far behind.
And many think it'll only be a few years,
maybe, from AGI to superintelligence.
So when are we going to get AGI?
Well, until recently, most AI researchers
thought it was at least decades away.
And now Microsoft is saying,
"Oh, it's almost here."
We're seeing sparks of AGI in ChatGPT-4,
and the Metaculus betting site
is showing the time left to AGI
plummeting from 20 years away
to three years away
in the last 18 months.
And leading industry people
are now predicting
that we have maybe two or three years left
until we get outsmarted.
So you better stop talking
about AGI as a long-term risk,
or someone might call you a dinosaur
stuck in the past.
It's really remarkable
how AI has progressed recently.
Not long ago, robots moved like this.
(Music)
Now they can dance.
Just last year, Midjourney
produced this image.
This year, the exact
same prompt produces this.
Deepfakes are getting really convincing.
(Video) Deepfake Tom Cruise:
I’m going to show you some magic.
It's the real thing.
(Laughs)
I mean ...
It's all ...
the real ...
thing.
Max Tegmark: Or is it?
And Yoshua Bengio now argues
that large language models
have mastered language
and knowledge to the point
that they pass the Turing test.
I know some skeptics are saying,
"Nah, they're just overhyped
stochastic parrots
that lack a model of the world,"
but they clearly have
a representation of the world.
In fact, we recently found that Llama-2
even has a literal map of the world in it.
And AI also builds
geometric representations
of more abstract concepts
like what it thinks is true and false.
So what's going to happen
if we get AGI and superintelligence?
If you only remember one thing
from my talk, let it be this.
AI godfather, Alan Turing predicted
that the default outcome
is the machines take control.
The machines take control.
I know this sounds like science fiction,
but, you know, having AI as smart as GPT-4
also sounded like science
fiction not long ago.
And if you think of AI,
if you think of superintelligence
in particular, as just another technology,
like electricity,
you're probably not very worried.
But you see,
Turing thinks of superintelligence
more like a new species.
Think of it,
we are building creepy, super capable,
amoral psychopaths
that don't sleep and think
much faster than us,
can make copies of themselves
and have nothing human about them at all.
So what could possibly go wrong?
(Laughter)
And it's not just Turing.
OpenAI CEO Sam Altman,
who gave us ChatGPT,
recently warned that it could
be "lights out for all of us."
Anthropic CEO, Dario Amodei,
even put a number on this risk:
10-25 percent.
And it's not just them.
Human extinction from AI
went mainstream in May
when all the AGI CEOs
and who's who of AI researchers
came on and warned about it.
And last month, even the number one
of the European Union
warned about human extinction by AI.
So let me summarize
everything I've said so far
in just one slide of cat memes.
Three years ago,
people were saying it's inevitable,
superintelligence,
it'll be fine,
it's decades away.
Last year it was more like,
It's inevitable, it'll be fine.
Now it's more like,
It's inevitable.
(Laughter)
But let's take a deep breath
and try to raise our spirits
and cheer ourselves up,
because the rest of my talk
is going to be about the good news,
that it's not inevitable,
and we can absolutely do better,
alright?
(Applause)
So ...
The real problem is that we lack
a convincing plan for AI safety.
People are working hard on evals
looking for risky AI behavior,
and that's good,
but clearly not good enough.
They're basically training AI
to not say bad things
rather than not do bad things.
Moreover, evals and debugging
are really just necessary,
not sufficient, conditions for safety.
In other words,
they can prove the presence of risk,
not the absence of risk.
So let's up our game, alright?
Try to see how we can make
provably safe AI that we can control.
Guardrails try to physically limit harm.
But if your adversary is superintelligence
or a human using superintelligence
against you, right,
trying is just not enough.
You need to succeed.
Harm needs to be impossible.
So we need provably safe systems.
Provable, not in the weak sense
of convincing some judge,
but in the strong sense of there being
something that's impossible
according to the laws of physics.
Because no matter how smart an AI is,
it can't violate the laws of physics
and do what's provably impossible.
Steve Omohundro and I
wrote a paper about this,
and we're optimistic
that this vision can really work.
So let me tell you a little bit about how.
There's a venerable field
called formal verification,
which proves stuff about code.
And I'm optimistic that AI will
revolutionize automatic proving business
and also revolutionize program synthesis,
the ability to automatically
write really good code.
So here is how our vision works.
You, the human, write a specification
that your AI tool must obey,
that it's impossible to log in
to your laptop
without the correct password,
or that a DNA printer
cannot synthesize dangerous viruses.
Then a very powerful AI
creates both your AI tool
and a proof that your tool
meets your spec.
Machine learning is uniquely good
at learning algorithms,
but once the algorithm has been learned,
you can re-implement it in a different
computational architecture
that's easier to verify.
Now you might worry,
how on earth am I going
to understand this powerful AI
and the powerful AI tool it built
and the proof,
if they're all too complicated
for any human to grasp?
Here is the really great news.
You don't have to understand
any of that stuff,
because it's much easier to verify
a proof than to discover it.
So you only have to understand
or trust your proof-checking code,
which could be just
a few hundred lines long.
And Steve and I envision
that such proof checkers get built
into all our compute hardware,
so it just becomes impossible
to run very unsafe code.
What if the AI, though,
isn't able to write that AI tool for you?
Then there's another possibility.
You train an AI to first just learn
to do what you want
and then you use a different AI
to extract out the learned algorithm
and knowledge for you,
like an AI neuroscientist.
This is in the spirit of the field
of mechanistic interpretability,
which is making really
impressive rapid progress.
Provably safe systems
are clearly not impossible.
Let's look at a simple example
of where we first machine-learn
an algorithm from data
and then distill it out
in the form of code
that provably meets spec, OK?
Let’s do it with an algorithm
that you probably learned in first grade,
addition,
where you loop over the digits
from right to left,
and sometimes you do a carry.
We'll do it in binary,
as if you were counting
on two fingers instead of ten.
And we first train a recurrent
neural network,
never mind the details,
to nail the task.
So now you have this algorithm
that you don't understand how it works
in a black box
defined by a bunch of tables
of numbers that we, in nerd speak,
call parameters.
Then we use an AI tool we built
to automatically distill out from this
the learned algorithm
in the form of a Python program.
And then we use the formal
verification tool known as Daphne
to prove that this program
correctly adds up any numbers,
not just the numbers
that were in your training data.
So in summary,
provably safe AI,
I'm convinced is possible,
but it's going to take time and work.
And in the meantime,
let's remember that all the AI benefits
that most people are excited about
actually don't require superintelligence.
We can have a long
and amazing future with AI.
So let's not pause AI.
Let's just pause the reckless
race to superintelligence.
Let's stop obsessively training
ever-larger models
that we don't understand.
Let's heed the warning from ancient Greece
and not get hubris,
like in the story of Icarus.
Because artificial intelligence
is giving us incredible intellectual wings
with which we can do things
beyond our wildest dreams
if we stop obsessively
trying to fly to the sun.
Thank you.
(Applause)